Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number which is
2192. David P. Now I want to address the question
asked in this voicemail seriously, because
many of you have been asking it. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Chris from Portland.
Yeah. So, you know, I really was hoping that
you'd be able to share with the listeners
the process that you go through to vet some
of these Republican candidates that you have
on your show that you're interviewing, because
they almost seem so consistently wacky. Yeah, it's
like you're cherry picking them now. I know you're
not. But it seems like you are because they're
all just out there. So if you could explain the
process that you go through, that'd be great.
I mean, that person today, Alison, she really
did say it all. Yeah. All right. Thanks. Bye.
Speaker 1: So, listen, many people have written in
and said, David, why don't you interview the more
intelligent, articulate and reasonable Republicans
running for 2022? Why is every person that you
interview completely whacked out of their gourd?
Here's the reality. We cast an extremely wide
net. Very, very wide net. And I'm looking now
at emails from my colleague John about all of the
different people that he approached. It's dozens
of candidates, dozens of candidates. Some of
them are more reasonable. A couple of weeks ago,
I interviewed this guy, Johnny Teague, who won the
Republican primary in the Texas seventh District
and he might believe JFK Jr is still alive. Fine.
But he he was more reasonable, at least in terms
of some of his political views. We cast a really
wide net. Most of these Republicans don't want
to be interviewed by me. I think many of them
research us and they look at past interviews
I've done and they turn us down. I've also told
you that we've had probably five or six who
have initially agreed to be interviewed, and then
something happens between when they agree and the
day of the interview and they bail. We literally
never hear from them again. In many cases, they
just they don't show up. They're not on Skype.
When we're supposed to be interviewing them,
we never get an explanation. So some of them bail
because of that. So what you are seeing is not me
cherry picking the craziest Republican candidates.
It's these are just the ones that are ending up
on the show for one reason or another. And some
of them are completely out of their minds. Like
Alison Hayden yesterday, she was really nuts,
scary, scary nuts in a way. On the other hand,
we also have other candidates who have just
not shown up. So we really are trying to get
a diverse representation of what is going on
on the Republican side right now. And listen,
Johnny Teague was more reasonable. Alison Hayden
was more bonkers. And, you know, John Gibbs was,
I guess, somewhere in between or something like
that. But we are not cherry picking. And so many
people are you know, sometimes people will say,
David, why won't you debate Ben SHAPIRO? I've had
Ben SHAPIRO on and we've invited him many times
and he doesn't accept coming on. Now, you can say,
Well, that's because your show isn't big enough to
be worth it for him. Fine. But don't tell me I'm
unwilling. You can't say, David. You're unwilling.
And then I explain he's welcome. And then you say,
Well, yeah, why would you do your show? Okay,
but the point was, I'm willing. I'm willing.
That's the situation. We're not cherry picking
the crazies, but I think it bears mentioning
that a lot of the Republicans running this year
are completely nuts. We have a great bonus show
for you today. The British pound has plummeted
to a record low against the dollar. We will talk
about the implications and the reasons and more.
I am going to weigh in on the chess crisis wherein
top player Magnus Carlsen has accused another
player named Hans Niemann of cheating. It has
taken the chess world by storm and we will talk
about it. And also, Brazilians are about to vote
and there are viral election lies. There's a lot
of Trump stuff being said by Bolsonaro, all of
which we will talk about on today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, the bonus show is
great. I would love for you to sign up at
join Pacman Dotcom. Get access. Get in there.
It's going to be an absolutely fantastic thing.
We'll talk to you very soon. Join Pacman
dot com coupon code invite gets you a disc.